[Music]
who do you hope
um the next conservative leader will be
and who do you think the next
conservative i'm not going to make any
predictions about what's what's going to
happen
you cannot have decent public services
if you don't have a strong free
enterprise economy and i think one of
the most exciting things that's
happening now in britain
is the new generation that's coming
through and i think that we need a
simpler tax system because the easiest
way for corporations or in fact
individuals to dodge taxes if you have a
very very complex system we're going to
see some really bold policies that can
transform britain in a positive way
[Music]
well i agree that the that you can't
separate
social and economic issues i mean to me
the most important issue is freedom it's
about people having control over their
own lives and you can't have social
freedom without having economic freedom
if you don't have control over your own
money if you can't chart your own future
you are not truly free i don't believe
it is the government's job to decide how
many hours you work or what your role in
the economy should be or what investment
that should be in the economy i want to
see people more empowered to do that
themselves and i think we do have a
exciting new generation who are more
likely to set up their own businesses
more likely to want to live that type of
life and i think the problem we've got
with politics at the moment and i think
why there is a demand for political
change
is that we've seen a very technocratic
managerial approach to politics so it is
what vince was talking about about the
tractor production statistics people
don't want to just hear
a bunch of stats from politicians about
however things getting better they want
to feel that they have a role in shaping
their own future so i think there are a
lot of issues around devolution you know
britain is an over centralized country i
think we should be giving more control
locally of course the ultimate locality
is the person themselves
being able to make those decisions i
think also there's a rebellion against
focus grouping and the idea that you can
get a successful policy by simply just
testing it with the public and seeing
which thing is more popular which
started off with blair and brown but
frankly has been carried on in more
recent years as well and i don't see
this as an entirely new phenomenon i
first got interested in politics in the
1980s and it was much more ideological
there was much more of a debate about
what sort of society you wanted to live
in what you wanted the future of the
country to be like and i think there's
an appetite for the public to hear much
more of those types of discussions which
are essentially about values
and richard and i disagree about what
those values ought to be
but
what it certainly isn't the case is
there's just one way of doing things and
it's simply a question of whether you're
a good or bad manager and i think that
turned people off and one thing i really
like about the new politics is more
people are involved people can say what
they like about the brexit referendum
but a hell of a lot of people went out
and voted if you remember say that some
of these elections in 2000s it polled
belief you know lower than 60 of people
were voting and participating in
politics and one thing no one has
mentioned so far is social media social
media has given power to people to have
a voice in the political debate which
they simply haven't had before and that
you can see the impact of that in the
u.s you can see that impact of that here
in britain and some people don't like it
but my view is previously those those
discussions weren't being had you know
the
the the number 10 grid was managing uh
what would be talked about each day of
the week that simply isn't true anymore
and i think that's a good thing so i
like the fact that we're now in an age
of talking about ideas and
i think that
politicians on the right need to respond
to that
[Music]
i started my career off in shell so i've
worked for a big corporation i've also
worked in government and what always
strikes me is how similar the
organizations are of and how different
they are whether it's the internal
politics whether it's the bureaucracy
and most people you know go to work
every day trying to do a good job
regardless of which organization they're
working for but the idea that these are
totally different animals
i think is mistaken i think it's a very
similar structure they work to and i've
i agree with this this point that it is
essentially the new entrance the people
who are disruptors and prepared to stand
apart from the crowd where those new
ideas are generated and why can't we tax
them yeah why
my colleague is looking at digital tax
but one of the important things when
taxing corporations is making sure
you've got global agreements to do that
to make sure that you can tax them in a
way that doesn't just allow them to move
their profits because we know companies
like starbucks have been able by
claiming that you know it's was a
trademark around their
mermaid thing you know that they've you
know he's based in the cayman islands to
get around the rules so you have to have
rules that work and i think that we need
a simpler tax system because the easiest
way for corporations or in fact
individuals to dodge taxes if you have a
very very complex system so that's why
i'm a big fan of tax simplification to
achieve just that but you know there's
no such thing as
free money or easy ways to tax
there isn't i can tell you and anatol
made the point about tax rates being
much higher in the 70s but what's very
interesting is the tax burden hasn't
actually changed very much for the past
50 years it is about 37 now and it
stayed roughly the same regardless of
who we tax and
it's the same people that always end up
paying it
[Music]
and if you look at our pension system
and our tax system it's still designed
around the idea of a paternalistic
employer
i don't think that's what the balance
between employer and individual should
be i want people to feel that they have
power over their own pensions
over their own child care arrangements i
want them to feel that they own
their own future
so i'd like to see pensions owned by the
person
rather than the company
paid directly into
the person's pension account
in the same way we now do with child
care vouchers
and i also think that with the advent of
fiber we can see
much more flexibility in terms of the
way people work
well i hope we can see more people
working for multiple employers being
able to build up a portfolio as they go
for their life i mean i don't know if
any of you have read the book the 100
year life
but i'm certainly
expecting to be working for quite a long
time we're all going to have multiple
employers so it's important that we feel
that we can own
our future security that we can own the
flexibility around our lives and we can
own that ability to shape our future i
think that's really important i think
the tax and benefits system has a lot to
catch up on in terms of the way people
live their lives because if you're
anything like me
you'll find that there is endless
complexity in terms of things like
pension arrangements it's not simple
it's not transparent about what you do
child care is something in this country
that is still
a massive bind for many many working
parents
and i do think we've got fantastic
primary schools but often they close at
three o'clock one of the things i'm
looking at is the potential to pay
primary schools more if they open longer
hours to provide on-site child care so
that they're more flexible for working
parents because i think we need to
adjust the services of the state
such as education and health to the way
people live now
not the way they used to live in the
1950s or the way they lived in the 19th
century
[Music]
well the fact is that britain's economy
was in a dire situation in the 1970s and
it was turned around by a series of
supply-side reforms
made our and also money but what i would
say now
is we do face a different set of
challenges but we need to apply
free market mechanisms to solve those
challenges say for example housing you
know richard talked about 1945 i think
one of the worst legacies of that
government was the town and country
planning act which essentially made huge
sways of our country impossible to build
on we're now in a situation where
well the green belt in london but we're
now in a situation where people in
london who are renting are paying 50 of
their income in rent if you look at a
city like tokyo that has much freer
panic planning policies the rents are
much lower people can afford to live in
that city so that to me is a
protectionist top-down planning policy
it isn't a free market policy that's
i mean if we had a freer policy if we
allowed building around stations in our
greenbelt which would be much more
environmentally friendly than putting
those houses in the countryside because
people would be able to accumulate into
work we could build a million homes for
young people
in our greatest city so that so that to
me is a radical solution to a social and
economic problem which is giving people
more power over their own lives and i
think the labour party aren't willing to
take those kind of steps
[Music]
i think what we've seen is different
nation states have more power than they
used to so we've seen a huge growth in
the power of eastern nation states in
particular if you asked does the chinese
state have more power than it used to
yes it does you know it is stopping
people
speaking freely it's arrested arresting
political dissidence it hasn't been
doing that for quite a long time
what's what's changed is that
it has a hell of a lot of economic power
which it didn't have it's a growing
economy it's growing relatively on the
world stage and i think that's what
we're seeing so i don't think we should
conflate the
issue of corporations versus nations
with a changing
sense of where power in the world lies i
think it lies in different places and i
think that's what we're feeling here in
the west so but so you don't think it's
a so you don't think actually it's a
function of globalization you think it's
a function of the declining power of the
west and increasing power of the east
or i think that is what people are
feeling and i think that's sometimes
seen as
it's because corporates have more power
i don't think that's true i think it's
because we are seeing the power migrate
elsewhere and that's essentially based
on economics you know we've seen a huge
growth in asia over the last 20 30 years
and it's continuing to rise
[Music]
i think one of the most exciting things
that's happening now in britain
is the new generation that's coming
through
and i think this is a different
generation from ones we've seen before
i describe them as airbnb
uber riding delivery eating freedom
fighters and i see some people in the
audience shaking their heads
but
you know we we see opinion polling shows
that younger people are more like to set
up businesses so there's been an 85
increase in 18 to 24 year olds setting
up businesses in the last four years
they're more likely to have a side
hustle alongside the normal work they're
doing
whether it's running a youtube channel
whether it's renting out a bedroom on
airbnb
whether it's
running working in the economy in
different ways and i think it is because
that generation has grown up
with more freedom than previous
generations
more information at their fingertips and
more capability
and i don't think it's surprising that
that generation believe in lower taxes
than older people generally do
they're also more interested in things
like public service reform
so i think that shows that there are
people
out there who want more opportunities in
british society
and i think that over the next few years
we've got the opportunity to
get that energy
use that energy and help britain become
a more successful economy to get rates
of economic growth up but also to raise
the opportunity of every individual in
this country to help them live their
best life so how do we do that
well first of all
the free enterprise economy is
absolutely key to that that is the thing
that gives people the ability to be able
to take control of their own destiny you
don't have freedom
over being able to live your own life if
you can't control your own money and
that's why i think it's so important
that we keep
taxes low
on people particularly on those
businesses that are just starting out
where people want to take a risk they
want to aspire they want to do things
differently
i also think that we need to make sure
the government is doing less better
so i've been doing a series of spending
review roundtables around the country
talking to people about where they want
public money spent and what people say
is they want money spent on core public
services like the police or education or
health
making sure our roads work and i think
that is where we should be focusing our
efforts
and too often i mean we have seen a bit
of a
creep creeper plant of a government
where
we now have 305 different quangos and
regulators which cost 2.5 billion and we
see more and more
regulations placed on
people's everyday lives and businesses
so is it really the business of
government to be saying to people how
big their pizza should be
or what the minimum price of a glass of
wine should be i would rather the
government is focusing on those core
basics they're going to help people get
on in life
and if the ultimate devolution of power
is to the individual which i believe i
believe firmly that we need to empower
people and as people become more capable
more informed they're better placed to
take decisions than the government are
but as that happens i also think we need
to devolve more power to local
authorities
[Music]
well i think the conservative party
needs to be bold
i don't think it's good enough for us to
just justify the status quo i think we
need to show how we're going to make
sure there are more houses particularly
for younger people to be able to afford
to get on the housing ladder i think we
need to show what we're doing in terms
of taxation because we need to get
economic growth up we need to
drive the economy forward and we need to
ultimately allow people to be able to
keep more of their money so
what i'm hoping from the leadership
elections is that we're going to see
some really bold policies that can
transform britain in a positive way we
need to show how britain can become a
better place say for example how do we
make sure that cities like leeds and
manchester in counties like norfolk
are as fast growing and as productive as
london that it's a great place to set up
a business to have a life
to me those are really important as well
[Music]
my overall message is that
we are not in a state of perpetual
decline as a country we have lots of
opportunities we need to open them up
and we need to make some tough decisions
so areas like opening up the london
green belt
making our schools
offer
higher levels of child care those things
can transform people's lives but most
importantly they can give people the
freedom and the feeling of control that
they own their own future thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv